bum bum
hello hello hello
why is this all whopper job
are we live
right on time
hello
how we doing today
dad
nope your dad's still getting milk it's
not me i'm sorry
okay sorry
oh
i did not mean to do that
nope
still working on the milk
what's up miro hi everybody
death buster bizarre
oblivious odd cameron claudia
claudio
have you seen the new zio storm
zion storm
vod
no
my day's been really good how about you
help me get a quote on your insurance
why
because my name's jake
you think i'd help you with insurance
i can help you get toe insurance
first day of high school
wow that is rough i hope you have a good
time
yep marshmallow head
i'm very good thank you for asking
are you into assassin's creed
i haven't played
uh assassin's creed in
years very long time
uh i think i played black flag
i didn't play odyssey
i didn't play valhalla uh
they've been kind of i don't like him
very much anymore i used to like him
though
yeah is there a um
isn't there a sony
uh thing going on
sometime soon
like announcing stuff
yeah black flag was a w dude
do you like odyssey i haven't tried it
it just didn't look
very good i don't i i've actually heard
odyssey's good
and then valhalla is not
very good
why can't i hear the water
is the audio all jacked
i can't hear the splashes of the water
can you
what the heck
tokyo game show banking amco is gonna be
there
okay
when is the sony thing
oh it's my armor
that's right
it's such a mosh posh of armor that i
didn't even know what we were doing
good point good point
man it really silences it dude to a
point where i thought there was
something wrong with the game
we should probably go find eg i think
when we left off we tried to fight that
dragon and we died
and we died
yeah
nice
zoli just released a video to clarify
that the finger reader crones don't have
four
arms uh
did she say they did
what
so you're saying she had to release a
clarification on that that kind of sucks
were people
mad
yeah i really liked assassin's creed
brotherhood those are way back in the
day though you know
what's up mug
uh it's good not as good as black flag
like they have good quality but overall
i prefer black flag i feel like it's a
bit
smoother they're saying an older game is
a bit smoother
interesting
the crones hold their cane with their
toes
interesting
why is death's poker so good i think
once we get it fully upgraded it's gonna
be a lot better
oh god
whoa
there's a crab on top of the
let me open it okay
there was a crab on top of the thing up
there
high rocket
i ghastly
i don't think we've had anything
ridiculous i would say the most
ridiculous thing we've had is ranala
replace margat
that fight was weird
okay at least we weren't that far away
uh i don't trust anything ubisoft makes
anymore
which i think is fair
oh i got the death prince puzzle
that doesn't really help us with
anything and a red main painting
uh
stop moving
oh my god this crab wants me dead dude
whoops
whoops
no we have not seen melania yet anywhere
i want to know what's in here
that was not worth it at all
unless you guys want me to wear a dress
i don't think a grave glove warts ever
been there before
yes this is a randomizer
i want to say something about the
randomizer but i feel like your shock
will be even better excellent
i like the way you think because that's
probably true
three
uh we went and fought soldier of godric
wait whoever play it was a rune bear
which wasn't that exciting i'm not gonna
lie
a rune bearer replaced
godric
yep we're playing i could have click
baited the stream hardcore and just said
eldon ring
dlc
it's out boys
and we just play the game like this
how many people do you think would be
like what
really
no no no
that's no good
all right eg let's see what you got
okay pony
you calm down
what you got eg
well
i presume
i find it weird that he just completely
stops stalking me right there
yeah i downloaded the mod of course
how would it not bomber 2 which is
normal golden tail this is all
completely worthless
okay eg's trash unless we need a somber
two which we don't
yeah we need somber three
literally don't even need it oh god
i've never seen it reach that far
did you buy the academy key from that
merchant do you remember which one it
was
because i do not
unfortunately
i need to shave
welcome ava
i was thinking i think it would be fun
to do a randomizer mod but everything is
rick
scalable rick
first one in irania thank you
so just the one right here
that's hayata this one
elden ring insta drop a soundtrack
trailer post recently and the starting
few seconds of that trailer made me feel
like it was gonna be a dlc trailer yeah
but it wasn't right
is not
okay let's see what he's got
i love how you remember this and i don't
2500
okay we're gonna have to buy that
because there's like no way we'll ever
be able to tell
uh how much we got
or like or we're never gonna be able to
find that
anywhere
we need a few more rooney boys
hello
why is this guy here
smithing stone
i'll take it um
trying to think of where we can get like
items and stuff i should probably go in
like a dungeon kind of see what's going
on there
here i have an idea
let me grab this real quick
i really hope they'll make a dlc um they
are 100
there's
i think it would be
if they let's say they don't make dlc
for this game
that might be the worst business
decision ever
of any company
ever
to be honest
actually might be the number one worst
decision
in all of business
if they don't
i i'm sure you guys can think of some
other stuff but that would be
uh
really bad
and dumb
straight up dumb
let me go over here
randomizer but everything is patches
yeah
that'd be interesting
imagine a scalable patches
we already grabbed those i don't know
why i went here because this is bad
i didn't grab this one over here that's
why
yeah this might actually be the dog
like the boss dog
ow
can't jump down there i will die
everything's alexander i think it'd be
fun to do rick just like is a meme
stream
we could probably try and kill that
dragon now
that'll be good
i'm gonna go down here though just to
see what's going on
elden god rick
yes sir
i think isn't there like a pickupable
item here
nope
there's one over here unless it's just
something on the ground oh it is
ew
i hate those
i hate those
i don't even know what they do
i think they're just like a lore item
what's your favorite weapon type to use
i like big sword go bonk
big sword go bonk on head is fun
just for me what is this
is there no item there
no it got replaced
oof
oof
i kind of just want to see what's going
on
i don't even need to crouch do i
just thought of that
because i'm all quiet
hello
okay
smithing three
does the randomizer give the outer god
of rolling a secret cameo
i don't think so
i will bonk them good rocket cat
did i miss anything no this is the first
thing i'm really exploring
i want to see what the boss is
think it's over here yeah
what is this boss usually the the giant
okay that's like almost unfair
i booted how are you
almost died
golden rune
dude all of these materials getting
replaced really sucks
makes you think you're picking up a good
item then bam crafty material yeah does
it
have you guys touched crafting in this
game
because i still have i don't think i've
touched it
at all
what is that
who is that stone digger duelist
i thought it was radon for a second
uh-huh hey
dead
how many fur calling finger remedies do
i have that's like five
i actually have five of those now
you're getting close to 100k subs
congrats thank you
i appreciate that hip hop
we are getting very close
never seen that boss that's a very
that's like a dungeon boss it's pretty
not rare
but don't see it often that's for sure
yeah how many of those do i have i just
check
okay it only says i have one i have way
more than one
i promise
okay let's go let's go buy the
glintstone key before i accidentally die
and you guys go jake what the heck dude
yeah i can't believe we sat we we
actually found dust poker
it was sitting on the bridge that goes
to the
first tibia mariner
planning anything special for 100k i was
thinking about that we also have some
other stuff that we got to talk about
guys
let me buy this first but then we we we
gotta we gotta talk we gotta talk
we really do
we we need to speak words
you're all in big big trouble
all y'all are in big trouble i'm just
kidding
hello
okay we got the key
so we're looking pretty good
now we can go here i don't even know if
we want to go here yet but
can't hurt right
what is the outer god of rolling
will you continue dark souls 2 play
through i am not planning on it right
now man i just really did not enjoy that
game
i really didn't i'm sorry
i really didn't i i am sorry about that
was not having a good time with it
best souls game
uh for some people sure
it's the fire giant
excellent it's just miyazaki
okay
like the guy who made rolling a thing is
that what you mean
what am i hearing right now
that's a definitely a dragon i'm hearing
okay what's down here because there is a
merchant
i love dark souls 3.
i would i would say bloodborne and dark
souls 3 are my favorite souls games
ah
anything but a hand
okay
for a second i thought there were two
okay we got this
talisman which i think is not gonna help
us goldenroom9
funk funk
funk
funk
yeah i got backslapped
i got backslapped bloodborne number one
i think so it's between for me it's
between that or or uh bloodborne or dark
souls 3 for sure
um
um
yeah there is loot down here we need to
check the merchant too
before i go any further
so you guys know the um
the
like tv show that i'm making
you guys even know about that like the
the next thing that i have planned for
for the videos
on the channel
oh he didn't play taran it's totally
different bro you got to give it a try
if you can
you do
i i need to talk to you guys about that
because i was working on it all morning
this morning and i'm like
i i had a moment today where i was like
i am way in over my head
way in over my head
on what i'm trying to do
i kid you not
i spent
two and a half hours
on a less than
two second clip
for it
and i was like
what am i doing this should not be this
hard
it
i'm i got in a perfectionist mode with
it
and i'm like
whoa
this is this is a lot
like because i'm using the camera mod
obviously to get really good
cinematic shots for it obviously
um i have to put characters in certain
positions to do this i have to put my
character in certain positions i have to
pan the camera in the way that i want to
zoomed in the way that i want to and set
up a scene the way that i want to while
all filming it in the exact right way
and there was it like a thing that i
just could not get this morning that
took me two and a half hours and it was
i think it was about two seconds long
and i was i just had a moment where i'm
like i am
way in over my head right now
and i'm like
there's a reason why vatividia has a
whole team around him to do this stuff
and i was like yeah that makes a lot of
sense because doing this on by yourself
i was like this might be
impossible
especially to get out in a timely manner
like i would want to get episodes out
pretty quick right like maybe one a week
maybe one every couple of weeks
this first episode
uh
could take me months
i i'm not even kidding
months
it it's so insane that like maybe i'm
going a bit hard with it
uh
i i am a perfectionist
in in some ways not in everything but
but in some ways
it's it's a lot
we have a spielberg in the making no
like imagine if
i had to like create the world
and everything like that like there's a
reason why
you know people that make tv shows and
movies and stuff there's like a giant
team around it
you know
yeah no i'm
yeah i'm not worried about
i'm not worried about viewage that's
fine it like
i would be disappointed if all of this
work went into like not the best
trending video you know what i'm saying
um
like
you guys know that a video my best
my best performing video took me 30
minutes to make entirely
it i made the radon video in 30 minutes
and i'm like i'm working on a video
right now that might take me months
so i i was really like
thinking to myself today
this i might be weighing over my head
and it
it was a bit demoralizing so
that's all i'm not saying i'm not gonna
do it i'm not saying like whatever but
it's i'm excited like i'm so
pumped for it and i want it to be really
really really [ __ ] good
that
it it will just never come out you know
it sucks
was the thing you weren't able to get it
it was it was actually nothing mug like
that that was that was the part of it
where i couldn't get my character
to move the way i wanted with with where
the camera was
because
i don't want my character to be standing
here like this
when he's
saying things that i'm voice acting
for the scene that i'm trying to put out
right i want my character like move a
little bit so i'll like have to time the
emote
that i'm using
with the shot it's it's incredibly hard
uh
incredibly incredibly hard
it so i just could not get my character
like do the thing i wanted
uh
which is hard because like if i were if
this were real i could just like tell
the actor i need you to do this
at this time and then they would do it
but i have to like control my character
and then i have to flip to my camera on
my keyboard
to
to get it in the right spot
it's it's extremely difficult
and booted i agree
you guys should like the video like the
stream i'd appreciate it
i don't know how much liking helps with
a um
with a
stream i'm sure it does i think liking
helps everywhere
um
as someone who worked in the industry
the most important thing is to take your
time and listen to your gut do you don't
fret about what everyone else thinks
i'm worried about what i think you know
like because i'm
like
spending all this time on a less than
two second clip i'm like man bro i'm i
might be just over my head right now
i think it really does
oh that's cool cameron
watch that tv show in a heartbeat
it's
i am a little worried that people will
be like yeah dude i played the game like
what is this
you know because it's essentially like
role playing
the story
does that make sense
like i'm voice acting a character and
getting these shots that i think are
that make it interesting so that it's
easier to grasp what's happening
whereas like
normally when you're playing the game
you're doing all these random things
that you like might forget about things
so
yeah
i know it'll get easier the way i do it
the more i do it
it it's just like
i don't know it takes up a lot of time
to where i can't stream like yesterday i
was working on it the entire day and i
wanted to stream bloodborne but i was
like i gotta i was like in a flow state
and i'm like i'm just gonna do this all
day that's what i ended up doing i'm
like man i really wanted to stream too
so and then i wanted to go golfing with
my dad and then i wanted to go take joy
for a long walk so it's like i gotta
you know
it's so much that i'm like i don't think
i can you know
it's what sucks
i want to be able to just do it
uh if i do that
without like destroying myself
then uh
it'll be out in six months guys and dlc
will be out and then we'll be on to
totally new stuff
so it's it's hard to uh
all i'm saying is we'll see right now
for sure
it's hard to say
i appreciate it i just wanted to get
that out there because i'm like man
i hate like being like hey i'm gonna be
working on this
and then like
a week or like two weeks later i'm like
guys this is way too much it's like well
why'd you even why'd you even do it
you know because like i didn't think it
would be this much
really didn't i didn't think i'd get so
like obsessed with every
every frame man
i really am
which is uh
difficult to say the
least
but
i'll keep trying
we'll see what happens
but there might be
yeah that's all
that's all i want to say it's just a lot
that's it
we'll play the randomizer though
i appreciate the feedback guys i do
thank you
well
it's been how can i yeah i bet nobody's
ever found you before my guy
thank you
okay we got a golden seed which is only
500 i'm gonna grab that
is this a mimicked here
oh
should i get this
is the members here even good anymore
i don't know
mango vanilla
i choose mango vanilla
it does it's an awesome idea i i think
it's a great idea too
i think i'm just in over my head
that's all that's all
still good
i
i
we gotta oh i should have got the sacred
tier do i have a
yeah yeah
yeah okay this guy's actually got some
stuff
i need that
what is this raises hp
stamina and equip load
uh excuse
me infinity upgrade to a weapon
hmm
should i get her tree's favorite
mimic maze makes randomizer easier which
allows for more episode production time
man
yeah that's a good talisman i'm gonna
get it
have a safe journey
have a safe jenny
right hand leave me alone
you have bitch-slapped me
once already
i already have the key to the academy
i got it off another merchant
the lore possibilities in a character
you'll role play damn
no kidding that that's the other hard
part is like uh
it's hard to choose which route to go
like
you guys want to hear a scene
uh where uh
you know godric
uh what does he say at the end he says
i am the lord of all that is golden
right
and he holds up his
axe
and
i have my character say
i don't know if this is cringe or funny
or whatever
i have my character say
who asked
and then it goes into like a nice
cinematic boss fight instead of like the
boss fight
like i have it all written out just
getting the footage to to do all of this
would take an absurd amount of time
how's that based
let's go who ass
and it's like the the two so my
character and like the cameras panned
out
and godric and my character are like
running at each other camera zooming in
it it's
it's so different from what i've seen
before it's just like man i really want
this to be good and i don't want to
[ __ ]
put out something that i don't like
or that
i can't put enough time into to to get
it
done you know
in a in a good amount of time
like it just be
that's the only thing i'm saying it's
just gonna take so long
so incredibly long
what's up og crawdaddy how are you
he got a bit burnt
look up storyboard templates break down
timing it will help so much
okay i'm definitely gonna keep trying
uh i just had like a bad i would say i
had a bad morning that's all where i was
like [ __ ]
what the hell
i'm like yelling at my monitor like get
in the spot
it's like i'm a director yelling at the
actor like [ __ ] move
it's my fault what is that
i'll figure it out i'll figure it out
y'all get to hear my struggles though
i'm going to complain
i am the lord of all that is golden
okay
uh i i i will this vintage i will that's
a good idea whoa look at that
y'all ever seen the academy with this
lighting what the [ __ ]
hello interesting
it's going good sunless how are you
record i'm making of
just have everything recorded
oh god here we go
what is this
cut it out sir
crash
these things are kind of pathetic huh
who's your favorite nbc in elden ring
alexander i think
i thought that was a pretty good line
though
i am the lord of all that is golden
okay who asks
okay
which if you think about it like did
anybody ask
because no
my character certainly didn't he doesn't
talk
which is why i'm like kind of doing this
because it's like man i wish there were
so many moments where my character could
speak
you know
like
uh what's a good example
like with melania
imagine you could tell her where mikala
is
i wonder if she would even attack you
but again it's a game so you can't like
think that way right but this would make
it a bit different
pick up the item
how many of those am i gonna [ __ ] get
bro
that's like six now
that's literally six
oh come on i really get poisoned from
that
what's your least favorite enemy type
the birds
definitely the birds
are you kidding
me get deathed
oh i got radon's great sword from that
[ __ ] frog dude let's go
okay that's an interesting hit
dog pope is the best
okay who asked on a shirt
i dream of telling melania where mikala
is
yeah it would just
yeah
it would be cool
can we talk about this
that would just be very interesting
so which which is why i really want to
like do this
and have it be good
because i think i think if i've learned
i think if i've learned anything from
youtube
in making content on youtube
what the
[ __ ] is happening okay i'm dead
great
i think if i look i learned anything
from youtube it's that uh
if you make
good content
people will watch it
you know
if you make consistently good content
people will watch it is there there are
a lot of people who make really good
videos and they don't get the views that
they probably
could
okay i don't know what bird this is but
it does a lot of damage
a lot
gives radon
yeah imagine give radon like hey uh so
like i can cure scarlet rot but you
can't like what's up with that bro
i can't i literally can't move
all right let's try that again jesus
christ
remember when i was just talking about a
bird
there you go
bro
i'm telling you guys hardest enemy in
the game
a bird
every time all right let's find out
who's up here
get out of my way peasants
[ __ ]
why there's so many birds man
i'm going for it
we're going for it
all right who's in here
why is it not moving
hello
i'm scared
this is such a small room for the sky
bro
oh
why are there so many birds in here man
like is this technically a bird
man
should we use our mimic i forgot we even
got one we should
gargoyle of ratagon
imagine someone sees that and they're
like dude is that a part of the lore
what
they're
they're a part of it
it's like
no
bro you're sp you're spreading false
information
i think
you you shouldn't you should take the
stream down
like [ __ ] christ
learn how to think for yourself
there are people who who do that by the
way that's i'm not making like that's
actually a thing
spoiler
i'm a part of the war
do i not have enough fp
lying on the internet's fun
is it
i hate your timing
i wish i could move or see you right now
that would be much preferred
yeah i don't have the fp to use mimic
yet
that's exactly where i wanted him to go
close
do you guys think it's hp
oh you might be right
there ain't no shot
there ain't no way bro oh my god
where where did he come from
this is worse than a moog
replacing godric
it's the it's the gargoyles from
oh no
oh no
um
this isn't no
you guys want to try moog again for fun
uh man this randomizer is uh hard huh
jesus
i know there's a chest in there it's not
gonna make the difference i promise
it won't
stop throwing [ __ ] at me man
nice
maybe
mimic
i'm dead with one hit unfortu
i did not realize that would spray
anywhere
okay my mimic's dead that was worthless
the mimic was not worth it guys not
worth it right now
i'm out of fp
looks like you can still spray that
without fp that's interesting
i got a shave
this makes me itchy
yeah it's good when it's plus 10
uh
i don't think that's gonna happen it
also just wasted our entire like health
bar
let's see how we do
without using it
why are you so fast right now
calm down
his moves are so slow that it always
throws me off bro it really does
got a little lucky
oh we might get lucky again
you [ __ ]
stop walking to the side my guy
die
how did you not get procked
come on why does he do that
there we go
so
you thought moog was lame
smoke's cool
i just jump over
okay he's gonna do it
okay i procked him during it
that's kind of interesting
i don't think it helped us that much but
here we are
we don't get to hear knee heel
okay that's actually pretty big
tuning in from work lfg 77 septillion
7776 delay
777 quintillion
[Music]
seven 770-7777 seven seven hundred and
seventy seven seven hundred and seventy
seven seven hundred and seventy seven
thousand seven hundred and seventy seven
brent thank you i hope you're having a
great day at work man
there we go
i'm pretty much dead though guys
i would really have to gamer up right
now to not die
really gonna have to gamer up here
might wear off right now
okay we did a little damage
i i actually like can't get near him i
don't think
okay
okay
brett thank you again man
i appreciate that
you guys really like your sevens here
huh
you sure do
got my fifth moderator
you guys think this is possible
let's see i have to use three vials or
three flasks
i have five
do i need more fp
like do i only need one bottle or two
[Music]
let's see if this makes a huge
difference we gotta we gotta do some
something here
okay we don't have that uh
this
let's see
g fuel sponsor win
uh whenever they ask
good
i do like their uh blue razz it's pretty
good
i think i was out of stamina
very nice
we can't wait we don't know where golden
seeds are my guy
go get more seeds
i would love that
okay good proc he's gonna do it again
i think there was one at a merchant
i think you're right
that was kind of a waste
dude that attack is so hard to avoid
that was a bad
that was bad
yeah dude just get more seeds and it's
like bro
it's a randomizer we don't know where
the seeds are
when around grave places pick up all
those items
run around the grave places oh
hey
you're not wrong where are the great
places they're like over here i think we
already did that let's venture over here
let's see what's going on in this area
because
we're getting kind of annihilated right
now
just heal
me heal
just knee heel
oh you guys are great
uh i did get the seed but i need more
than one to upgrade a flask i need two
now
i need two
grave caves
uh
the one by the dragon
yes
there are more though
let's go this way
i just don't think we have enough sevens
either that's a good point
more sevens are needed
seven seven seven seven seven seven
okay g fuel makes me burp a lot
apparently
hello
oh
nice block
it's rick
rick died on a bridge rip rick
there is a catacomb over here that we
could go through i'm gonna go up here
these ants are in weird spots
what is that up there
is that what i think it is
yep
he didn't die he fainted
that's true you're right i'm sorry
what's your favorite ending
um
i'd say the ronnie ending
i think that does the most
at the end of the game
like
the most change
all right let's see we got here
a lance talisman
attacks on horseback
rip
i think it does the most change
now
without um
burning everything down
like the chaos ending obviously
whoa
okay
we can see what's in the evergl
ever jail
no idea why i attacked him
up
what is happening over here
bruh
bruh
did you get the random items from the
shiny skulls
not yet
it's a good idea though
you want to play for me
how do i attack you when they're already
rolling
oh
if i heal i die where am i
you know what
dude
dude
let me up now
right now
[ __ ] you
this is what you get for being a ball
idiot
nothing
all right
okay
i i don't know if i've ever seen that
there's a snail over there
i just want to see what's in here
it's melania
how much you want to bet it's melania
blade of mcclellan
god of roy
this i can deal with
hahaha
[ __ ]
wrong button
that wasn't worth
i hate you
this damn wind attack
my bad
why is this breaking hello
[Music]
uh
it broke
what the hell
what is happening
okay there we go i fixed it
i fix
yeah what killed me
i was i was paying attention to my mic
this [ __ ] ball came back
what a silly ball
all right don't matter
all right let's see we got over here
we've got
a scary yay
everyone clap yay
[Music]
wow
that's amazing
oh my god i love that for us
can't even level
okay
okay
okay
wait what can we get from the mausoleum
i think it would be the same
i think it would be the same
yay
all right are there any item
locations out here
we got a merchant here we should check
out
there's a giant out in the water over
there
and what do you got homie
a secret's here
we already have somber too
pauses
okay
alisman pouch
i think we gotta get this
and the pouch i think the pouch is
extremely important don't you
you guys can't even see it i'm blocking
it but i think we should get the pouch
it's 4k though
yeah i think that's worth
i think that's
worth
uh because we only had one up to this
point
raises maximum hp should we do sore seal
back to bow range
it's kind of our next best
one yeah thinking long term that'll be
better
imagine we can kill one of these bosses
man eventually
we actually have like
getting past the wolf
where the wolf would be with those
gargoyles in that tiny ass arena is
going to be ridiculously hard
where are they going
this is cool but there's an item
yeah i am sneezing
i'm sneezing
let's go over here
it's not a skull it's a dumb little crab
thank you
my allergies are going
nuts this is cool
yeah that spells okay we're just not
i can't think about that stuff right now
i think we gotta
i think our ultimate goal is leveling
death's poker to as much as we can and
then building off of that this is what
we want
smithing
one exalted flesh
isn't that a grab attack
inescapable frenzy
i don't know how many somber twos i have
but it's a lot
that's a lot of runes
okay all right we can have a really
interesting build here if we really want
to
the jar cannon
hell yeah
hmm
oh come on what is your range
we need to get out of here now
yeah we have like talismans for arrows
and stuff should we do that
i don't know
it's just hard
this makes the game pretty interesting
though doesn't it like i'm having a good
time with it though
like i'm having a really good time with
it it's fun
um
level
i still can't level
okay let's go check
uh
there's a dungeon over here i believe
like right over that way
we should check that out
oh
i did not look
it's fun to watch good
i think this is the last day we're gonna
do this though guys
like i plan on streaming all day
for a long time um
we gotta start bloodborne
tomorrow
i was gonna start bloodborne yesterday
but i got i got so caught up in
the video
look left and right before jumping
yes daddy
where is it
isn't there uh something over here
[Music]
i think it's more this way actually yeah
it is
what are you clipping oh
that's still just a normal rune
that's a weak sauce
there's another skull
only works on npc type enemies
are you serious oh you mean like
grabable enemies yeah i see what you're
saying
yeah the skulls still only give you
golden rune ones that's kind of that's
kind of lame
why would the chat not be live
guys am i tripping on where this cave is
there it is
you can do i don't think i have any
elden oh wait i have the um
you're right
you are right oblivious
i should do that let's see what's in
here though
what are the chances that item is worth
zero
wait
zero
it is live would it do why would the
chat not be live
like what
if it's not live then you're not live my
guy
yeah
yep
i like the randomizer it gives us a lot
of options to uh
we have a lot to think about you know
it's cool i like it
i don't remember this dungeon very very
well
oh god
i didn't want to hurt the jellyfish man
okay
okay
i did not want to hurt the jellyfish man
you're gross
guys how many somber twos do i have
that's another one
another one
not even close
don't
[Laughter]
you dumb [ __ ]
okay sombra one
why are you mad stop it
there's someone in my left
[ __ ] you
why are they not moving
oh come on
dude
okay
okay
okay
okay
now we go up her
no
stop it
stop what you're doing
what
this is really not how i wanted this to
go
is this an enemy right here
here is
how do i how do i get this to move
there we go
hello
hello
um
damn uh
damn
what are you i love how they like look
what they do with the sombers they take
the entire texture of the rock that the
sombre would be on and put it here isn't
that incredible
or like just weird
well they can't hear me because of my
armor
this is pretty damn good then this armor
set
i didn't think it was that effective
oh of course i have turn yeah those are
great
amazing
lovely rock
indeed what a lovely rock
they did it right there too
all right let's see what kind of boss we
got is there
yeah we're fine
yeah i still don't have pants because i
fat roll when i put them on
i refuse to take off my helmet
i hate these things man
it's not that bad it's not that bad
imagine it was a
what are the the other scions called
yeah these aren't that bad
great dragonfly head
three of them by the way
we caught three of them
all right excellent yeah the revenants
that's what i'm thinking of revenants
is that a good reward
that's what we got for like helmet-wise
you guys think i should still wear the
crown
i think so
that wasn't worth it at all
how many runes do we have though we have
10k
so
that's not awful
uh let's level actually now that we're
here
it's a randomizer what do you expect
uh
you're right
that's very true
what does um what is the scale with
a smoker strength decks
int
somebody said yesterday don't even think
of anything else
upgrade int
which
yeah
kinda
hmm
i don't really know what to do
we're not gonna be able to respect
anytime soon
i'll just put it in
let's go duplicate that remembrance
endurance
no
i think you get a lot of stamina in this
game
like bass
you really do
i didn't think putting in one point to
vigor would be worth it i think if we
had like five to ten points i'd put more
into vigor but we're not
wow i love that for me
i really missed you in those dungeons i
really did
i missed that
exactly that
was great
jesus
i love that
am i too sarcastic
it might be
believe me
i think that's one foot
okay i'll be more sarcastic then
i think you have to be a little
sarcastic to play these games
is that enough for you to fall
come on there we go
what are those pants you think i'm
wearing pants
imagine wearing pants
no
no no
these are my legs
ned flanders is here
all right let's duplicate that [ __ ]
now
should we use the runes
or should we go to the round table and
see we can get out of it because i
haven't even talked to enya yet
actually i don't even think we can talk
to enya because we haven't beaten
a god nope can't even talk to her yet oh
this is a rare occasion god you're ugly
i can't remember the last time
you look great ronald not ronaldo nice
to see you again roderica my name is
rodrika
i should have told you sooner
isn't this place impressive though
the round have you encountered a problem
where elden ring just crashes when
entering stormfront in paler's catacombs
i had a similar problem in a different
area
if you're playing on steam
verify the integrity of your files that
fixed my problem
although
it's a little bit it's roger
i'm still looking for my own purpose
good for you
okay what can we do here nothing should
i use the runes
we should go to the twin maidens and see
what we can buy first but let me sell
these
it's hard to say it's a hard call isn't
it
it's 50 000.
hold on
do we want
any weapon from the elden beasts i don't
think we do
i don't i don't want those items no
we have the items we want i should use
the runes
yes
i'm selling these fur call remedies
exalted flesh this [ __ ]
okay
now
let's go over yonder
i got some calling bills let's see
everything we can get
i know they'll be randomized we need to
check
offer bang
bang
bang
purchase
already bought the golden seed we can
buy another sacred tier which would
actually be extremely helpful
uh
not a ton
i am melania not the best blade of
mickeleh i think we got to get this
tyria be an unstoppable bubble paladin i
believe in you you want me to be a
bubble paladin
that actually could be really fun tom
if we get more of that stuff i'll go for
it man
thank you for the two dollars again i
appreciate you thank you
yeah we got to get secrets here
what are these physics temporarily boost
intelligence
not yet
maybe now let's go level
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
useless i
the physics can help a bit
not uh a ton
but a bit
we need to find golden seeds
okay
got four levels
vigor
i think so too
all right
boys
it's mogan time i think we can actually
beat moke
there's a potential
there's potential
now that we have more vigor
we have more healing
uh i just kind of have to pop off and
get good not gonna cap
do you think you'll ever play diablo
four
uh i don't plan on it but maybe
i'd love to play other games on here
that'd be fun
popping off boys popping off here we go
i almost procked them i almost procked
them i shoulda
come on
burn [ __ ]
let's go
he's gonna do the thing
okay we're just gonna go for it
it didn't kill me
this is good this is good
time to get good
dude
doing any melee
oh
okay
it's definitely possible
i
i don't know like there's basically no
time to melee him it feels like in his
second stage
it's pos i could totally tell this is
possible now though i feel it in my
bones
did he just go for two of those off the
rip
i should get nafeli i think you're right
we keep saying that and then i don't
bad dodge by your boy
good
don't kill me
nice
[ __ ]
he's just so insane stage two he really
is let's go get nafeli
i think that's a good call
let's go get her
if she's still there she might not even
be there boys
hit that pot
that pot went flying
i don't think she might she might not be
here anymore
because i didn't talk to her in time
there she is
and all her drip look at her drip
drip drip if you intend i ask you
i'm certain
this thou witness
no
we didn't
you're trash
this is one of the hardest bosses for me
at this point i think so too this is
really hard
maybe not as hard as the gargoyles in
the ratagon's red wolf room that's kinda
nuts
all right nefeli let's get this [ __ ]
my understand doesn't nafeli have like a
ton of health
for this fight
like for even the godric fight
just want to get a hit in there
man very unfortunate timing very
unfortunate
the health department's not going well
near for nafeli right now not going well
for nephilim
however she can heal
i like that
let me get a backstab
nice
just try and get as much out there as i
can there we go
this won't kill me
one heal
to heal
another proc
oh he jumped right over it
right on over that huh
hello
why did that not hit
all right well nafeli's [ __ ] dead
look at how far he can throw that
i'm scared
come on
croc
[ __ ] you
okay he pulls that out pretty quick you
really do
better
feel
this is not good boys this is not good
shouldn't have done that
i procked in his mouth though good
almost did it i'm glad i didn't
oh my god
we got a little distance
rocky [ __ ]
i was looking at my [ __ ] too much
i you can use your mimic and nafeli at
the same time
it's not worth it
i don't have my mimic upgraded at all
the mimic dies
so quick
i think nephili is a good distraction we
need to get we just need to get good i
ain't gonna cap
i got hit a lot there
we need to get a little bit luckier
in some ways
okay i backed up there that was smart
it's actually a really unlucky
thing for him to do
get him to philly
we're gonna do this instead
come on
that's not bad
no i didn't need to heal there man [ __ ]
rip nephili
rock
damn it
this is bad
i don't even think it's worth a try
dude he throws so much blood
everywhere bro
i wasted a flask unfortunately
i kind of panicked
we need to get uh we didn't need to get
lucky
with like what he does to nafeli
stage two he just annihilates her almost
we can beat him though i feel i feel it
it's just gonna be really hard
nice
take a little look
there it is
yeah i'm trying to be more aggressive
this won't kill me
heal
don't heal i don't think this will kill
me
it killed me
[ __ ]
that would have been close though
because look nafeli's still alive
we can do this
we can do it
that proved to me that it can be done
i didn't think it would kill me that
must have been so close to not killing
me
we can do it we can do it we can do it
we can do it
yup
i gambled too much of a gamble
[ __ ] you in your weird ass attacks
this is why no one likes you this is why
you were banished to the sewers
i have to heal once
which i think is fine
as long as i don't get hit again
you didn't proc
no fellaini's getting [ __ ] on
this is what we want this is good
use this
nafeli is unfortunately dead boys
now i know it won't kill me
that comes out so quick
just spammed
my man's spamming out here
all kinds of blood you need more vigor
you need a better mentality
i've seen people beat this game without
leveling it's it's possible
we did not get lucky with nafeli
we need a little luck here it can be
done
ew not bots the [ __ ]
did i not spawn or chat
all right
brandon what the [ __ ] did you just say
did you smack your keyboard and press
enter like what the hell is that
i did upgrade vigor
i smacked this keyboard
come on
okay let's try
this is my range
that was slightly unlucky
heavy attack after heavy attack
there we go
now he's not dude come on give me the
thank you
do the thing
i don't have stamina bro
[ __ ]
there we go
proc
this won't kill me
what a gamble
let's go to philly
what
huh
we'll take it
don't move you [ __ ] don't move
bro his second phase is actually insane
here come the bots
christ
here come the bots
brent you guys gotta like we didn't get
lucky again i [ __ ] up a couple times i
really did
we can get lucky this is it
this is clearly possible just really
hard
don't gotta give up
just gotta get good
that's really unlucky
yeah
i'm getting kind of [ __ ] right there
the fella's getting absolutely
annihilated
good
why are
good
damn it
i didn't think his swing would hit me
from there i'm like directly behind him
and he can hit me
i gotta be on his left side
remember that i gotta be on his left
side
that's my bad
[Music]
stop walking that way
come back this way
no
i guess a proc will work
that's not bad
hold on
this is actually really good
holy [ __ ] i thought i staggered him
whoa
legion
what is that
hold on thank you so much holy [ __ ] i
have no idea how much money that
actually is
thank you my goodness
come on come on come on come on
get him to philly
yes
yes
i don't have any fp though man
hey thank you legion i appreciate that
dude
it's too early
got me backing up in a corner
okay he's unprocessed
i have a little bit of fp
do i have like i can't look at my
inventory
i can't
i need him to calm down
keep backing up from
can i still do this without it wait look
at this
nope i was wrong
it
it dude if i use a runark will it work
i have to make sure i'm safe
what the hell was that
it did nothing
okay
okay
i have i have a heel
you [ __ ]
stop spamming [ __ ] everywhere
he's all over the place
god
his first stage is so calm compared to
the second
goodness
i needed a starlight shard that's why i
didn't do anything
uses fp to mimic nearby objects
it's clearly possible it's clearly
possible stop telling me to farm bro
shut up
i want to do it like this
shut up
when you go and do your playthrough you
go farm
no
i'm gonna beat my head against the wall
like a real souls player
i could have put one more flask in fp
i need to be aggressive i need to be
aggressive
can't be no [ __ ]
can't be no [ __ ]
i hate you
i hate you
right now
okay not proc not proc not bra
you should do a thing yep this is good
this is what we like this is what we
like to see
good
no fellaini you worthless [ __ ]
sorry that was mean
glitch out
i like that that's good
how am i alive
what's up trey
one more and then a heal
we need to use all the fp we got all the
fp
you
son of a [ __ ]
is he standing in it
i can't tell
he's not no philly's standing in it
going after me bro
i feel like we didn't say it
so it's a 20.79
super chat thank you very much
legionnaires
i really appreciate that
trey i texted you i said i'm both
i probably won't stream that much on
twitch
but you can stream on both now which is
cool
do you guys think the magic grease will
do much
i could put on the scarab head
that's a good point
or is that the right scarab head aren't
they specific
go go go
go go go go
this is really good he's gonna do his
dumb [ __ ]
okay really good
crock croc
he's still standing in it
nephili's got a ton of health
it didn't reach it didn't reach chat
i could pack it up
nice
four flash
oh i'm worried about her
he's probably gonna unproc here soon
why is he just backing up
god damn it dude it's so [ __ ] hard to
tell
i have no more fp
he is literally just standing in the
fire
i got to change my flash
but we have enough heels
i actually tried to jump over him
i'm scared
why am i doing 111 damage
so
why did i back up bro
one hit
it's the witness
okay okay change
i need one more fp
and we're okay
yeah sore seal gives us a bunch of other
[ __ ] dude
what does source he'll give us it gives
us uh
greatly raises attributes
which
i guess it wouldn't matter that much
okay
let's do that
do this
where i have
one more fp flask
okay
what did you guys said raise my fp
this
or this
yeah i know sore seal takes more damage
but we're putting out never mind it's
fine like i took it off
we can do it i don't think the magic
grease is gonna do [ __ ] i really don't
moog is weak to bleed that's pretty much
it
we clearly got this
we got a system let's do it
okay
that's all right
this should wear off soon
um
okay
go ahead
good
won't die
good
eel
fp
nathalie's good
unprocessed
what the [ __ ] did he just do
going into fellaini
he's so nuts
go back in the fire
this is probably the worst place i could
be
he's literally flying around non-stop i
don't know what to do
we got unlucky with his aggro to be
honest in this one
i could play so passive and only procum
i'm
dude we we pretty much just got unlucky
there like he he actually just went
complete aggro mode
okay
guys stop telling me to change what i'm
doing this this can clearly work
different weapon even though this is
such a good weapon
the best one we have
okay
i don't know what nathalie's doing but
it's nothing that i like
his proc should end
yup
and proct
there we go kind of bad i got hit a lot
there though
so annoying
i thought he might stagger
cool
so he can do a full 360 with blood moon
i see that's kind of nuts
oh my god
does this feel scaled down
like this does not feel scaled to godric
in any way shape or form just saying
maybe it's because stage two any heals
maybe that's where i'm getting that like
the healing thing is what kind of takes
it out
and just like how insanely aggro he is
in stage two
might make it seem that way
bad attempt
like a baseball
why like what is he backing up for
what
is that
i missed twice great
i have no idea
okay
well
he's not procs
uh i might die if i don't heal
run run run
okay hopefully he walks into this
back up back up back up back up back up
bam
wow
like his second stage is absolutely
insane
it doesn't feel that insane when you
actually get to him because he's like
you know you're strong enough to fight
him at that point but like holy [ __ ]
that is my only gripe with youtube
gaming or like youtube streaming is
those [ __ ] bots bro
can i wear these and not
okay i mean that's something
uh
i mean we don't have a physic so we
can't use physics
because we haven't found a physic yet
um
yeah i have opera gx
i like opera gx
um
now we went to the physic flask and it
wasn't there
kind of think
yeah low level in the aggro is nuts
opera gx is definitely the best uh
i didn't get in a fella did i
all right well let's use this to learn
his move set let's go with that bucket
oh i did get no feli good
good good good
great
okay
i'm cool with bullying him for a minute
there i like that
no that was a bad proc
decision
that was close okay nafeli should
distract this is good too
get that off it's hitting him
excellent
now my god holy [ __ ]
spam these
i have no fp i'm i'm upset
it's not even reaching them
holy [ __ ] man just calm down
why
i thought i was on my god damn it dude
one mistake and this shit's over
[ __ ]
you haven't played elden ring in a month
excellent decision you and 95 percent of
the player base man
oh i want to do this so bad just like
this i really do
harry his blood i'll parry your blood
i will parry your blood
wow that is
nuts
well
that's not good
that's fine i needed to reset
he's a blood bender oh no
okay
it's so doable guys it is
if i do everything right we can do it
we just got to be a god gamer
which we are right
i don't i do not like it when he does
that attack it destroys nephili
look at that
i jumped over him finally
nice
his proc should end like
right now yep
do
this rocked up
i think i had to do that yeah that's
fine
let's get good boys let's go
yup nathalie just stood there like an
idiot
excellent he was not even looking at me
scary
extremely scary
he's kind of hogging out he's kind of
pogging out rock you [ __ ]
he's harder to proc in stage two
walk this way
that's fine walk right here
got him
got him [ __ ] ass
got him [ __ ] ass
wait for very clear openings
very clear and then procs
no longer proct
run away run away
do this
he's so fast
damn it
can't get that bleed
kill
knee heel knee heel knee heel knee heel
knee heel
okay
that's some good [ __ ] right there that's
good that's good [ __ ]
stop walking to the side
[ __ ] you
why are you so fast
this is not good
i knew it
i'm glad i didn't do it i almost did but
i didn't
go go go go go
that's fine
walk right here baby
right there mm-hmm
i'm bad
i was not paying attention to my fp
the [ __ ] ledge of the castle saved me
oh my god
wow
that was insane
damn it
what what the [ __ ] is hitting me there's
still fire over here really really okay
back up fast
yep
yep
yep
big hits
castle save me again
come on
i'm keeping this plan
this sucks look look how far that went
keep doing that
come on
is it not hitting him i don't understand
i'm at fp
[ __ ]
come on
big gamer
[ __ ] you
i am the lord
of all that is golden
and one day
we'll return together
to our home
wow
[ __ ]
wow
we got the dectus medallion for that
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
god
boys we got good
i did the i did the souls thing i got
good
congrats your poker is officially bigger
than moogs
thank you
thank you
you were fit to graft
i got yes
i got both deck dishes
nice
that's actually really good
worth
totally worth
i can't believe i did that when i ran
out of fp i was like bro
i gotta go for it
i got i gotta i just gotta get good and
not get hit by anything
i got hit by some stuff
are you are you kidding me that that
gave me 15k
15 000 runes that's nothing
i can level up one time
you guys think that entire thing can go
into a youtube video
that whole thing was like
actually insane to me
one whole endurance huh
i'm leveling up vigor
beat his head in the ground that's not
even who we fought but i like it
[ __ ] you raven to the bone
pushing me about like that and after all
that crafting
where did that get you
you dumped
on me
what's up to you
step back you mentioned tarnished
[ __ ]
yeah i'm about to get his bell bearing
i've gone complete shura mode
there it is i couldn't do
what i
like no you can't because you're dead
mogu is strong against frost so we
basically made that extremely hard on
ourselves is that what you're saying
good
good i like that for us
yeah i might make that into a youtube
video just to put out there because i'm
extremely proud of that
i am very proud of what i just did
because they are like you need to go
farm
you need to go level up bro and i'm like
no
i'm gonna beat my head against the wall
until i do it that's what i did it
didn't even take that long
oh god i forgot what she's wearing
i don't have a grate for you honey i'm
sorry hello
there's someone there nope what you
doing nope nope nope
you have to go farm hey listen that's
actually really good advice by the way
it's great advice
i think i think that's safe to say that
might have been a certified gamer moment
that that was straight up a certified
legitimate gamer moment
i think
all right let's go uh
let's go to the dectus
uh the the lift
uh no there were the two gargoyles in
where the um
the red wolf of ratagon is before ranala
so that's a no-go right now considering
we did all of that
to get one level
but we got it we got the dectus
medallion that's cool
all right if i make that into a youtube
video what is the title
i'm so quick on these bots bro you have
no idea goodbye you're nerd
eat
the best adult dating site
no it's a bot it's not even a person
felon can help me with gargoyle ratagon
is that true
killed god free mode first try nice
you can't see my nudes if you want but
they aren't very good
is that who i think it is
we're going for it this is the one
that's hurt in pharah missoula
what did i kill
give me a good item [ __ ] you
what
what what what
yeah let's go
give me a good item
worth it
worth
great item
what a good item
i love that for us
bone peddlers bell bearing
okay
hi james do dragons technically count as
birds
is a hot dog a sandwich
these are the questions we need to ask
okay not worth
yes or no is a hot dog a sandwich
hey can anyone even activate these
things
i don't think so
yep
are they they're not even throwing it oh
no
i can't think of anything worse to have
here
a hot dog is not a sandwich
my character is very breedable today
thank you
submissive and
all right let's get the heck out of here
bro we're making progress today
progress
more magic grease i love that for us
hot dog is a beef tube taco
is a taco a sandwich
you guys are saying a hot dog is a taco
like straight up a taco
spoken echoes linger here
words of queen america if you wish i
think cereal is soup
yes
i think a hot dog
actually is probably more of a taco
but does that make a taco a sandwich
but it's like a
it's like this
like you whole like it's like this right
a taco
but this is a sandwich
that doesn't make any sense does it oh
well
i don't care
uh no [ __ ] off tell me
i don't know why i talked to her there
ketchup is a juice
you're a juicer
dr pepper is barbecue water
i'm glad we're having this talk
oh god
the one problem with youtube streaming
are these stupid bots
that keep making new accounts
i report all of them and nothing happens
how is cereal a soup think about it
think about it it's literally a soup
you know
we're the gargoyles
replaced
you guys want subs only
is that a thing
is sub only chat a thing on youtube
you got to subscribe
i'll make it member only
how about that
all right what's this
wow
submissive and breathable
wow
[Music]
i'm broke guys you can you can become a
member to this channel for three dollars
but if you need to save three dollars
then please don't become a member but i
would appreciate it if you did
because we don't have a lot of members
on youtube and there's not really a
culture of doing so on youtube yet
but i would like to change that
y'all are broke all right
that
bet
do a flip with torrent
hmm
maybe maybe
you play 40k ain't got no money
understandable man
you do you
are these always a map
yup okay so the maps are the same
ow
your granddad is a pro at fortnight
that's pretty cool
who we got here
great
not the worst thing i've ever seen
is that an eagle yeah no i'm not going
near that
are you guys want to go to radon
i think it's time
and i haven't even gone that way yet
[Music]
uh we won't go here
hello that is all i will be as a cool
uncle i don't think i want kids i'm
pretty sure i don't want kids
[Applause]
[Music]
that might change someday but right now
i would i would love to be the cool
uncle
would
i think i'd be a good uncle
maybe not the best dad
how long were you fighting moog it's
like five minutes right guys
it wasn't that long
right
the random festival
well let's see what you got
yes
shut up and give me what i want now
uh
i don't think we need a memory stone
it's 500
i'm getting this that's like nothing
um
this guy's trash
straight up
trash
bad
okay let's go this way
yep five minutes easy peasy
where are like some items i can get man
i feel like i'm not even finding
anything
i just want to see who radon is let's go
[ __ ] you rat
dude do the dragons just like
they just replace the dragons randomly
but all the places where a dragon is
there's still a dragon there
i did melania first try a new game plus
three
wow
you're so impressive oh my god
can i have your autograph
you're amazing
i think i love you
damn
oh
boy
nice
okay i don't think we did that much
damage there
we are straight up doing nothing on this
guy right now
um
okay we're gonna peace we're gonna peace
we're gonna peace we're gonna peace
nope
we learned and we're moving on
leave me alone
all right take your guesses who's gonna
be gideon
yeah
who's gonna be gideon who's gonna be
radon
watch it be radon
anya let's go fitzy
i love that for us
find fortification
channels dragon
blood flame talons
okay good to know
radon will be ratagon okay
let's get the [ __ ] out of here
uh we already fought ronaldo where
margaret was
you think it'll be a goat
imagine a scaled radon goat
launches up in the air and a
goat becomes a meteorite
melania
soldier of godric
yes
indeed
oh no i'm gonna get [ __ ] slapped
we're good
rock sling is actually good right
i think rock sling is still like op as
hell
i'm not sure though
you think it's gonna be for the sax
hmm
okay
the deer spirit
let's go find out
that might be the best spell
i have the level intelligence anyway
keep keep that on the brain boys
keep that on the brain
i'm lazy bones thank you for the 79
euros
i am millennia
blade of mackwela
thank you
excuse me
79 cents i don't i don't know what sense
is equivalent to euros i don't have no
idea
hello
hello
god i love this area
i have a texture pack that makes the
game look better like this is how it
normally looks
and this is with the shader on see that
difference looks good bro
what up blind
blind looks exactly the same
alexander looks the same hope he looks
different
[Music]
the festival is
i want to watch
this before we begin let's hype it up
with radon's cutscene and then it'll
just be something dumb
what's your currency kirby
general radon is cursed ever to wander
yeah gold mask is speaking what the heck
good point
lazy bones thank you again
thank you
it's kind of you as well
oh brazilian gotcha
i think 79 cents euros is like a dollar
usd
yeah that's what it says
howling at the sky
howling at the sky
but now
we must make mary he still has the same
sword gathering of champions all right
let's go
shut up
let's go
there an item over here
yep
wait what is this
okay it's an item
grease and beast blood dude that makes
me want to play bloodborne
just hearing beast blood
[Music]
we'll start bloodborne tomorrow we're
going to get as much out of this
randomizer today as we possibly can
oops
godskin noble bracelets
great grand wonderful
all right place your bets place your
bets who we got who we got who we got
who we got who we got
i wonder why that super chat hasn't gone
through yet
it's [ __ ] reichert
[Laughter]
it's [ __ ] reichardt this works
this is actually cool as hell
whoa
this works
let me pick up these items
do you think we still get the cutscene
all right let's go
[ __ ]
okay that was cool as hell bro
he is not meant to be on a hill of any
kind
this is sick
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
i think he's i think he's broke
i can't get the bots right now sorry
ignore the bots
ignore
that is weird
that is weird
there we go
nice
[Laughter]
this is very interesting
all right what is gonna happen now
[Music]
that is uh that is it
so riker was holding back the stars
i am melania oh blade of mickeleh
cheese
[Laughter]
that came in so late
at the perfect time
jeez
thank you man
i appreciate it
yeah we got moog
we killed moog
yeah was that bleed infusion
that was anti-climactic
of course it was i had a good time
though
we could go to volcano manor
also is it the serpent hunter like
really good
like on its own like this
which because it does not require any uh
leveling at all
you can scale it
right
but uh like with strength
but it the attributes required is zero
so that's pretty cool
hello
i don't know what do you guys think this
this or dust poker
right now death poker is better
obviously
we just got a lot of rooney boys
that's good
plus nine record fight hits like a tank
yes it does i think it hits like a tank
no matter what
you guys still think poker
i do have a lot of smithing stones as
well
i have a lot of somber twos
which i guess we could just use because
we have them right
could have sold these
are we guarantee if we kill alexander
are we guaranteed
his talisman
should we find out
we're not doing his quest line
it should be
random what if he gives us something
good
you get a nerfed version
i mean we i guess we could do his quest
line and see what we get after
i just have to talk to him here
that's all we got to say and now he'll
be a volcano manor
which i think i want to go there anyway
okay
i won't kill him
i won't kill him
we're good
uh
let's see what we can do
let me solo her build i don't have
those
items
let's see what we can do with the
serpent hunter because the serpent
hunter is
legitimately extremely good
i have a somber one i already used two
on my main weapon so i'm cool with using
this
i don't have a three still
now we're doing a hundred and fifty nine
sixty
if we level strength
this could be good
this is already quite good
no we don't need the old like it's it's
actually extremely strong despite itself
the thing is though i think it's only
good at plus 10 like fully upgraded
it's only good at that
so i think we keep doing that's poker we
keep leveling intelligence
we have rock sling
so
we don't have a um
staff yet
it's an option let's go with that it's
an option right now
okay
okay
let's level
i wonder if we can respec after we kill
ranalla
this makes this makes decision making
really hard actually
we have six
levels we get this up
and this up
you're right we do need larval tears
[ __ ] ass all right
can we go back to uh
let's see do you guys want to go to
volcano manor do you do we want to try
our luck at the gargoyles again
let's see how we do with the gargoyles
actually
cuz we're a bit stronger
i want to see what's in that chest i
know i'm just gonna die when i go over
there though
that's pretty good cameron
it's not bad
that is though
having this room be as small it is as it
is
is the hard part
do these guys proc
they might not proc
okay i'm doing awful right now
well i'm dead
hmm
i'm dead
yep
i think serpent hunter here would be
better
since they don't seem to proc
with the uh
is it frost i don't even know what i'm
procking
i thought someone said it wasn't
i think this will be better
they can't okay
it is frost
i'm just trying something out kirby like
we're just we're trying things if we're
like nah this ain't gonna work
we out we out
you know how it is
what's the next lore hunting stream
uh
not anytime soon i'll tell you that
it's not bad
dude [ __ ] these guys honestly
oh come on
oh i'm dead
does reporting work better
and then hide
because they're all slightly different
variations of the same bot that keeps
spamming my [ __ ] channel
okay i reported first and then hit them
um
this seems like a no-go boys
i ain't gonna cap
i mean yeah those bots on youtube have
been awful
for a very long time
so i don't know what they're doing about
the bot situation
it's pretty bad
oh that one
i'm literally stuck
his ass stuck me to the wall and i
couldn't do anything
let's go to volcano manor because this
this is not happening this might be
harder than moog
for real for real for real
let's go to volcano manor let me use uh
diet
i was stuck in the cheeks guys
it's not a bad place to be but it ain't
great
not those cheeks
i guess i could just go to volcano manor
couldn't i
i don't know why i'm going this way
should we just go to volcano manor
i guess we should because we're already
at altus
let's see what's down here
okay
we couldn't even do it anyway because
that's not even a character
somber three
no
gimme item now
if i die in the area i'd get teleported
like for real for real
okay let's just go since we're already
in altus
we can just we can go there
we can go see what the god skin is up at
the top of the village
let's go in this way see what we got
and we'll go around
how am i gonna get into the city
a lot to think about
oh god
it isn't the abducator that actually
counts are you serious
i thought it was when they grab you and
put you inside
their uh their compartment like in the
middle of them
i've killed the merchant for a funny
laugh before it's it is pretty funny
oh [ __ ] my ass sideways
oh
no guys
oh no
run go go go
go go go
and go here for now we'll come
back got a bell bearing
hell on earth that's what that was
hell on earth
okay
um let's go up here and see what's this
way
yeah even when there's both of those uh
tree sentinels there i always run past
them i never fight that battle ever
honestly i just think it's bad
are you
actually serious right now with that
bear
how about no
on the bear
situation
okay
how about no
lame
it's a big old fat no in my book right
there
we've turned in a lot of these ball
bearings
back from work welcome home
welcome welcome welcome
[Music]
you want to get rid of this guy first
he is literally ghost flame how short is
that it's right on his crotch
that hurts him pretty good
i like fighting this guy in his own
thought it might stay short that'd be
great
[Music]
run
i didn't have stamina
[Music]
almost died
[Music]
i'm an idiot
see why did that work
you see that
okay come on
[Music]
i could not have thrown harder
i i'm literally standing there like i
forget how this attack works and i
thought he was gonna keep spinning and
he just didn't
damn it
i thought he was going to do the big
spin
and he just like did one spin and
nothing
man that's a [ __ ]
i feel like i was fighting him for an
hour
okay
[Music]
clearly possible though if i don't just
throw like an idiot
ow
[Music]
okay my character just wouldn't throw
wouldn't roll
my bad
jump attacks only
uh
i mean
the attack's really quick i i could just
i need to fight him just straight up
like i know how to
[Music]
why are you walking
are you going
really close to the other guy now
keep walking keep walking that way
please thank you
[Music]
did it go around
kinda
cool
so
this one does a lot of damage man
a lot
i guess he always does
there we go
[Music]
oh i got stuck
thought he might stagger there no way
are you
i swear to god if his health comes back
i'm leaving
it shouldn't
dude
okay
oh my god you're an annoying [ __ ]
all right
[Music]
there's just like
i'm leaving i don't even want to do it
now
i don't like it
i don't like it
not even fun leaving going somewhere
else
let's see who's this way
when you get him that low twice
that's demoralizing
who's gonna fly out of the sky here
jump attacks made him stagger until they
don't
hello
what a replacement
yep i was not feeling that one
golden seed
is margate gonna spawn
this is gonna be margaret
wretched flame of ambition
the wing scythe
and thorpe's barrier not bad turned into
a [ __ ] flower dude excellent
oh esther thank you for the
says four months
thank you man i appreciate you
welcome back thanks for being a tarnish
for four months good to have you
now roth
oh my phone's dying uh oh
class
yay we finally have more flash excellent
so hard to get
let's go this way
see right there guys that is uh
that
is
a tick tock right there him turning into
a flower
i should grind on tick-tock a bit more i
still don't have a great rune so i don't
even think i can get in there yet
the become a member link isn't working
for me
in the description
it worked for us sir
what am i hearing right now
i'm scared
stop it get some help
with the crystalline doing
being an idiot
oh thank you coach i'm glad you like it
um
hello
i think becoming a member on are you on
mobile
is mobile is bad
mobile don't work so good
oh god
watch them dance like imagine if these
characters were dancing
and now they're all gonna attack me
run run run run run
i should go to the falling star beast is
a falling star beast a ball god please
no
wow that frocked so fast
oh god
press one in chat if these guys are the
worst bosses in the game
huh
okay
this is big
[Laughter]
he just
nothing happens
man you do a lot of damage
oh my god i can't i can't dodge
ah
i love fighting the crucible knights i
hate fighting these things
maybe royal revenants but they aren't a
boss
right
well
i literally don't even want to do that
at least we know what's up there but i
we don't have to be here obviously
[Music]
excuse me
there is a royal revenant there's one
boss
is that astol
no it's one of the
what a spot for you to be man
interesting
yeah
trying to maneuver the camera
like that
really annoying
i don't know why i literally just always
hit stuff randomly
let's see what these are
well we'll never know
okay we might now
leave maybe
i thought that was alexander over there
for a second what
jesus
you've been watching for three hours now
good
you live here now my friend
just kidding
just kidding
it does gold mass change at all
oh this should be a good item maybe
never [ __ ] mine
all right gold mass looks exactly the
same
you love it here and that's good
good giant
stay right there my guy
oh those are not rats
that's a bear
bomber seven
that's a good pickup
it's a very good pickup
oh we got alexander here
what up boys
or a troll sorry
roll
yeah
i almost died
admit it you would have laughed
funk
where am i
i'm lost
there we go
do you all want a gold mask bikini
you think so michael okay you can see
okay we are going to start uh bloodborne
tomorrow by the way guys
i'll start stream around the same time
eruption
interesting
you
we are actually starting it tomorrow i
had [ __ ] come up yesterday
and then i didn't want to set up the ps5
today but we will start tomorrow
i'm able how are you
good night oblivious have a good one
you think they'll ever make a mod where
enemies have their attack moves
randomized
i think there is a mod for that or it's
being it's in development right now
that'd be really weird
bloodborne in all of its beautiful 30
frames per second
why they haven't remade that yet why is
that dragon there what the [ __ ]
what a weird spot for that dragon
i made it about six hours into dark
souls 2 and i did i just straight up
didn't want to play it anymore
cj
i just don't like it
i can see why some people would i just
personally do not
someone got lance mcdonald's fbf pat fps
patch
working with a ps5 really
how
how do you even patch anything on a ps5
yeah i'm sure
i'm sure the dlc is okay but i just
i i just don't like the gameplay enough
to keep going i don't like it
i have a cat oh yeah i do have a staff
i can cast a
[Music]
rock sling
if i have the uh
i need 18 intelligence
i have not checked out steel rising at
all yet no
welcome you can play it on stream if you
guys want
it didn't seem like there was a lot of
interest though
bell bearing
purchase
gold c for 300 gimme
number five
oh i got
nothing yet
okay we need to come back to that guy or
somber five
this is big
yes i did beat moak
it was
actually one of the best gaming moments
i've ever had i i clutched up and became
a literal god
do you love in the uk no
i live in america
america
i don't really like america but
here we are
living here
here we are
regardless
nicey
i wanted to be cool but i got scared
hello
hello
hello
um i don't know where i'd like to live
yet i'm i'm still pretty young
so i'm not like trying to live anywhere
crazy yet
i i'm thinking someday of living in
europe but i
that would be pretty far down the road
we got an avatar
that's pretty neat
oh you're
you're this one huh
great
what the heck is that one doing
it's walking in the sky
he's just walking in the sky
don't stagger me that much thank you
glitching glitching out
oh that's not good
i'm really glad the other one is just
glitched out completely
it was just walking in the sky and did
absolutely nothing
that's great
we'll take it
really good weapon
really good
like really good
damn
really really good weapon
if it didn't require 40 dexterity
suck my dick
what's up here
okay
dex l
dex l
just kidding dex can be pretty good
not something we've been putting it into
but
if we can potentially get somewhere
where we can uh
what is shooting at me
where we can respec i mean it's
potential we'll have to see later
because right now that's not possible
oh god
leave me alone
i'm going in here
whoa
dead flanders
that's high
all right what are these people gonna
look like
oh
tanith
wait can we
so that's gonna actually be tan it's
face
interesting i've never seen tan it's
face
we have one level i'm putting it to ins
i think that'll help
because we have a staff now to use rock
sling
what does it can it'll look like
okay okay
on you precocious
we rarely receive visitors to the
volcano her mouth doesn't move because
they didn't have to because she always
wears a mask and not so about the bird
if you have rise with her yeah [ __ ] the
eared tree your decision is most welcome
now you belong to the volcano manor
family the drawing room lies down though
i am tanning
thank you
i need that uh godskin prayer blick okay
okay the drawing room is through use the
key you didn't give me a key though
oh no
that's a problem
if this doesn't open
excellent
excellent
excellent okay
uh
how how the [ __ ] do we get in
let's go up here
he doesn't give me a key
all right who's gonna invade
milo shaded castle castalion
interesting one
almost died almost died
stop it with your farts
barts
he
uh you gave me a dumb shield
in somber 7 again great
[ __ ] your table
why haven't you beaten the game already
no beat the game like
really it's not that hard man
okay buddy
okay buckaroo
you can buy the volcano manor
letter from kali
that's true
where did we see him
he gave me one invasion right
yeah
that's a crater
he didn't give me anything
so
did you buy the glintscone key yeah
we're already way in there we can't uh
the boss we're facing there is
ridiculous
really hard
i'm trying to think
yeah we gotta go buy it i think he was
he was the merchant in caled right
this one
we could also go to nocron
no it's the
double
gargoyle
pastor
double poison gargoyle
in the radigon
red wolf of ratagon fight
it's dumb
i hate you stop it
wow
[Music]
okay we got the merchant down there
come come come come come
i don't think i had it from kali i think
it was this guy that we saw the
nope you're right was it kalei
i don't remember
malacath might be cool with ronald's
arena yeah that would be a little small
a little small
uh it's not this one
goodbye
well i have all my bell bearings i could
just go to the round table and turn them
in and we could see it there
unless never mind
i don't think i have enough seeds
oh god dung eater without his thing on
looks like vary
i don't think the flying books would
work because there's no kids there
offer yeah i have a lot of these
that didn't really work did it
um
trash
is weeping peninsula this one
secrets here
uh not here
the other one
of course
yeah i found the elden remembrance in a
swamp
there we go
so
but it's not the key
if i just turn in the red letter
will it
just in the
quest let's find out
but that's all the way up
or is it
yeah i'm trying to be
i'm not buying everything i see right
now
um
do i have to have the map open no
clearly don't
damn it
report
bell bearing shops are separate in the
menu they don't appear in the main shop
i mean i went through all of them
all of the menus
yes i beat moke
or do i have to
like do this
i see
okay thank you
i see i see
well that makes this extremely annoying
okay
ollie's
isolated merchant
i want to get the tier but it's 8k
that's kind of a lot
it's probably worth it though um
hello i'm confused
hello
like i'm wondering do i have to get this
to like
progress the entire quest line and do i
have to do the red one last
that's why i'm not spending all my money
right now
uh
not really toby not anything
recently
you don't then i bought this but it
doesn't come up
on the map
and i can't get into the room of volcano
manor because she gave me something
other than the key
the red one should be the haslow one up
here and i bought it but i don't have it
it's not here
find the red mark on your map with the
exact location
it doesn't come up
it should still be here even if i like
maybe i have to explore this way
you think
to tanith yeah do i have to talk to her
to activate it i don't
i don't think i do i never have before
hello
hello
i don't think i need to talk to her to
activate it the drawing room is through
the hole use the key see
she her dialogue is still the key
but i'll have the key didn't give me the
key
oh god
someone please what do you mean a text
file with hints i i don't want to do
that that's weird
what
maybe i have to discover the area for it
to work i do have the rolled medallion
i don't think we can get in the city
because we don't have great runes
hey we can go check
all right
i can't go in the drawing room you
foreheads
i'm stuck
okay
can't go in the drawing room you
whatever
there's another merchant over here
that's a big boy crab
oh god
not a singuleen
stay
you need to go in the drawing room no
[ __ ] okay whatever
i'm getting trolled now
damn what do you got on you bro
number eight nine
two nines
uh halo tree
i'm getting that tier i'm getting that
seed
okay
okay okay okay
try the bell bearing on here okey-dokey
this randomizer this randomizer gets
really hard spots man it really does
okay he's gone
doesn't he spawn in here
not at all what we want
this couldn't be worse
he's stuck
i think
is he weak to his own effects
imagine
ow oh god
this couldn't be worse i ain't gonna lie
i i literally can't see you
nope
bye
i mean
damn
wow
like get [ __ ] right
any other way to go about that
[Music]
he used my attack
what an idiot
yeah he wants his weapon back
all right let's see what we got going on
this way
i gotta get off pretty soon guys
hello
hello
uh excuse me
we must find rick
watch the like i think the elden beasts
will be rick that would just be so
amazing
okay okay okay okay
this he can stagger draconic omen killer
excellent
you do a lot of damage
yeah you just attack whenever you want
don't you
okay
rain
that's good cameron i'm glad you like it
why am i one-handing oh yeah
i had no stamina
i had no stamina
perfect
no stamina
nice
okay some of these bosses really easy
some of these some of them are actually
ridiculous i just got
i got a seed bed curse and 50k oh let's
go
this is going to be locked though isn't
it
it's not locked yes it is never mind it
had to load in
hmmm
hmm
still get 50k from that i love it okay
so that'll give us a rock sling i'm
pretty sure
let me make sure
that like let's say i use u which i need
48 for
and is my only
could i use rock sling
when i spell
yes i can
48 intelligence guys
that's poker goes with intelligence too
i think that's the that's our route
like would that just do no damage
i gotta plug in my phone it's gonna make
the noise just be ready
why was it like i wasn't using it why
was it never mind
it didn't make the noise
i remember malakath from last stream so
i can't wait for him to pop up although
i'm not sure totem
great poise damage
right
how are we gonna do this we don't get
great runes
without killing the boys
like from killing the boys we we don't
get them
are we gonna get great rooms from random
things
that'd be insane we need at least two
uh
okay this is beyond my brain power right
now so i think it's a good time
call it a day we went about four hours
um tomorrow
we are gonna do
bloodborne 100
we could go to nocron as well
i'm gonna call it for today okay
i got i want to make that entire moog
thing into a video i really do that that
was hilarious
and really fun
but i think we're gonna call it today i
need to go take care of my doggy it's
time for her to
take the fattest of shits
as we all know
she's gonna love it um
but yeah i hope you all have a great day
thank you for being here thanks for the
super chats all the subscribers we're
getting closer and closer to 100k
i don't know where we're at but it's
like almost 93 almost 93k
so we're about 7 000 away from 100k
which would be nuts so thank you all
very much for the support
i'm probably going to stream a lot more
this month than i originally planned
um like i said at the beginning of the
video
uh
[Music]
i i had a bad morning when it came to
the the tv show movie elden ring thing
that i'm making
um i'm gonna keep at it man but honestly
i might be in over my head on that like
it might be a bit too much
especially with all these bots um so
we're get we're gonna see i'm gonna keep
trying but
uh
i'm it might be a bit too much without
any help at all so
we'll see that could be a thing i do in
the future like when more dlc comes out
things like that um and maybe i can hire
people
and actually afford to do so
um
that would be cool but for right now
we'll see i'll let you guys know
i'm so quick with it booted it it's been
all day
it really has
um
yeah maybe more voice actors would be
fun
and maybe when we unravel the story a
bit more it would be cool so we'll see
man we'll see
uh
i'm just gonna stream a lot i i really
enjoy streaming on here so
i'm gonna keep doing it we're gonna
start bloodborne tomorrow like i said
but till then you all have a great rest
of your day we're gonna start around the
same time tomorrow
uh
and we'll have a good time with it man
so have a great day
peace out people
bye bye bye